[Music]
in cheese death you do cheese it so
nasty man
your life shows intolerance no I want to
tell yourself you see I like a stud
pizza cheese
a stinky cheese I like the cheddar
cheese I like the Mexican cheese vulajin
I like nacho cheese what do it your
problem blue cheese
mr. probably had a blue cheese burger
though I bet you're loving that is Bob
submitted by Steven or Stefan a father
of two has died after eating nacho
cheese sauce from a gas station one time
death by lethal gotcha
there's a gas station outside of
Sacramento were sacked out now one six
[ __ ] was good yeah so outside of
Sacramento there's gas station I'm not
gonna help you cuz I'm la I looked like
this oh why would you buy anything
edible phonetically that's true all I
heard was nachos and I got hungry so
this is what the gas station why would
you buy nachos from there I would that
just looks like something I grew up
around not be a chain for me to buy it
from no God like an NPN or 7-eleven or
something like it was stitched up with
garbage look at the spacing of the D and
food D and B who - again I by no not to
hear you're trying to go to Valley Oak
foo D and fuel mmm very old fool get you
I look like a gas station does normal
not for food nine people that have been
hospitalized and one person magnetized
and somebody [ __ ] take a dump in the
nacho cheese or something how many
people bought nacho cheese
they gave that nacho cheese yeah okay
did you to say nine people punch a mini
nacho cheese nine people when to buy
nacho cheese no try Brandeis people find
nacho Cano I thought one particular
location
nine people that bought it in like one
hour there have been nine reports of
people being hospitalized linked to this
change so there could be many more that
just didn't know because they're saying
that this is a gas station that like you
know there's a lot of travelers to go
through it so it's not just the people
of that town I have been affected so
what's wrong with the case so what
happened was someone [ __ ] up this
cheese was tested positive with botulism
was that mean also means that I got
contaminated it's not about true what
this does is it gives you droopy eyelids
blurred vision blurred slurred speech
and paralysis guys like me every day
when I get tired cause we're just like
taboo baby there's someone actually not
completely paralyzed one of the nine
people hospitalized we got control is
this person who owns this and he got a
gonna go to jail for that [ __ ]
right now I investigating to see where
the contamination happened whether it
was at the gas station or at the
manufacturing because what the wherever
how the cheese is [ __ ] getting sick
anywhere around the world
yeah okay died it's crazy
dude I kind of died from nacho cheese
man I know that's a terrible [ __ ] way
to go I mean like don't - [ __ ] get
bought up in a very happy thing and then
yes nice name at botulism it's like that
this toxin can be killed if it boils
will be their boiler property again
probably left at a very very lukewarm
type of temperature and that's where
it's just ooze bacteria are the same
toxin that you like with Botox that's
why I heard it before I didn't know
where what it what exactly it feels bad
Botox yeah and how's that that's why
it's ready inject into the muscles which
is it paralyzes your muscles are like
freezes it and that's why people can't
like move their face for those who'd
should put a fat [ __ ] deadly disease
in your [ __ ] your face to be beautiful
that's what I'm saying that's when you
when you fulfilling that [ __ ] Chinese
restaurant with that lukewarm water
that's that garbage get a [ __ ] out like
yo I don't think I can say usually
talking about rolling wine
sirisha look out of here dude that place
is disgusting if you could get that much
food for four dollars it makes it taste
really good like you I broke no more
with the memories of when I was broke
made me smile this bacteria is commonly
found in soil and sediment from lakes
rivers and oceans it bribes in low
oxygen conditions such as a canned food
nacho cheese deep wound and intestine
the intestinal tract tract so that's
what they're saying like that's where it
really really thrives and that's a lot
of canned foods tend to have this toxic
what I love to don't eat that is so bad
fun I should restate that because it's
not that a lot of canned foods is just
that this is typically found to be hard
to encounter yes so to be clear
one more game just to make sure you
[ __ ] heat your [ __ ] to a boiling point
[ __ ] I scorch my salon any Royal
nacho cheese out this what very supposed
to so it comes in a powder and then it
goes a little bit it turns into that
freaking good at solution oh I guess
I've never seen that yellow jizz do they
put water on it or is it just he I think
it just heat from what I've seen you
know that macaroni and cheese the one
that I feel like a warning bear beata or
a crap yeah that kind of fake cheese man
yellow five give me that [ __ ] yellow 5
and no milk cheese [ __ ] plastic
chemicals like cooking show like that
right it's like well today we're going
to have this delicious nacho cheese
we've added them together five it man
you know yeah I really you can't smell
this toxin you can't see it which is a
conflicting what they're saying because
they're like so be careful what you eat
with like will didn't you're not helping
me my calm enough
figure this out if it's there don't go
to any food be and delis yeah you could
talk them anything you know they found
out in a Hawaii they have a rat lungworm
disease assisting or like they rats have
parasites that comes from Southeast Asia
and then they take a Dookie and then
they die and then a [ __ ] slug comes
and eats that Dookie and now the slug is
a carrier that [ __ ] and it
they have a snail trail on your lettuce
on your [ __ ] vegetables and you
don't thoroughly wash that [ __ ] you get
that [ __ ] sorry no vegetable oh yeah
[ __ ] vegetables you could do what I
maybe you go all vegetables are healthy
and you get [ __ ] parasites well you
clean them right yeah fruits are so good
and get [ __ ] ecoli what does [ __ ] you
got to be [ __ ] careful with your [ __ ]
those people main gotta clean the wash
that stuff you know what's actually very
very difficult eating eating constantly
without eating processed food oh yeah
you know like going every day without
eating something that hasn't been
process whether it's brush it's [ __ ]
hard man like after a while I sing the
whole day which is getting vegetables
fruits and meat right the next day
you'll want that [ __ ]
give me some Doritos yeah like Hawaiian
men like to read all is because we're
addicted to it so it becomes hard
because you want the your brain to be
satisfied with the type of reaction you
get when you eat sweet stuff or very
fatty salty stuff but then Whole Foods
it is what it is it's just a grilled
piece of meat and you don't put things
on it you don't put like a lot of butter
and salt and stuff you just eat the
[ __ ] steak grilled like it is the
vegetable and then you start going
what is life it's exactly what a good
manners do all that dopamine level is
like I need stimulation so then you get
that [ __ ] piece of candy and you go
oh that's what house my brother used to
be a chunky or two but he lost all this
[ __ ] weight and this was during a
time that he went on this like fitness
craze thing and he kind of just
basically did the whole look at
Wolverine diet that his name but it was
when he was just doing a chicken and
broccoli but instead of doing a chicken
breast because it was too expensive my
brother did a ground turkey because you
could buy that a bulk at Costco when you
could also buy broccoli at bulk and he
all stood multi buys any hate net with
rice so he did that for like six months
straight worked under Phil got [ __ ]
cut and jacked
like a [ __ ] is pretty hardcore
because he just kind of did that
straight-up
unprocessed food diet and it worked out
but six months of that [ __ ] is pretty
miserable
I want to going on vaycay news fans hope
you guys liked that episode remember to
follow our personal social medias and of
course if you want to watch more videos
my friend should go where to go you're
suckers right up there
[Music]